hello everyone I'm Shahara I'm 28. I'm
in a long distance relationship and I
don't know if it's fun but a fact about
me is my motivation for going to law
school was to exclusively advocate for
men and family courts
so are you a lawyer now no no so I'll be
studying this this year what motivated
you to do that because I uh kind of
accidentally fell into I was mainly
counseling somebody who was going
through a divorce and they just couldn't
that they couldn't afford a lawyer so I
was like let me just see what I could do
and I was like I'm actually really good
at this I was combining all of these uh
I was doing all the big research and
kind of getting everything like looking
at his case and seeing you know what can
work and what couldn't and I was just
like I'm really good at this